meaningful but just not that meaningful
the day in Westminster we had expected
to have held the highest significance
for the country's future but now this
place has voted to change that meaning
that we're not that much closer to a
brexit resolution we're very stuck the
referendum was now three and a quarter
years ago we're still in the European
Union and no clear path to getting out
to wrecks it and you may say the
European issues much older than that
because it's broken so many Prime
Minister's MPs have approved a lepton
amendment put forward by former
conservative Oliver latwon it makes a
critical modification to Boris Johnson's
motion which approves his revised brexit
deal it says rather than improving the
deal the Commons has considered the
matter but with holds approval unless
and until implementing legislation is
passed in the broadest terms this means
that legally the Prime Minister's deal
hasn't been approved by Parliament this
is crucial because it means then another
piece of legislation comes into effect
the provisions of the Ben Act passed in
September that says that by eleven
o'clock tonight given Boris Johnson has
not got a brexit deal approved by
Parliament he must send a letter to the
EU seeking extension even if it's pretty
clear he doesn't actually want it so
perhaps as early as Monday we can expect
some kind of response from the EU the
government also want Monday to be a
defining day with the meaningful vote on
his brexit deal originally intended for
today but many people believe the
speaker will rule it out of order and he
could be facing a court challenge if he
hasn't made a proper request for an
extension but in all of this it's easy
to forget that election Thursday is the
last day Parliament can be dissolved for
a November election
so there is a majority in the House of
Commons for delaying Britain's exit date
from the European Union there's probably
a majority that has comments for Boris
Johnson's revised brexit deal maybe
maybe not a majority in the Commons for
a second referendum now when Parliament
can't agree with itself or the
government then normally there's a
general election
but it's not at all clear if at the
moment there are the numbers for that
but everything that happens next depends
on what Europe decides on an extension
it's not entirely clear that they've
made up their mind about the kind of
extension that they would be prepared to
offer a short extension would be the
easiest it would help them ensure that
breaks it is out of the way when the new
Commission comes into place in the
beginning of the December but equally
they could be looking at a longer
extension but everything depends a
little bit on the mood in Parliament
what could have been the most
significant day in brexit since the
referendum has now turned into a waiting
game to find out what Brussels says
about an extension Sam code Sky News
you